you know it's very difficult to say how
it goes about NATO here and Moldova
because in the last 30 years mother was
was a neutral country and our
politicians look at the neutrality as
the way of
not having Advance not being a part of
any uh Alliance so now when we talk
about the security and defense and the
need of our small estate you know with a
weak economy with a lot of problems
troubles you know to get into some kind
of Alliance and this kind of allies in
here in Europe now it's on the NATO we
have a resistance from a a part of
population and this part is mostly
russian-speaking population and it's
inflamed uh also by the propaganda which
is still really uh very uh
big in a in their and Powerful here in
the Republic plus we have some
pro-russian party which are supporting
that that
vision of a part of population that's
why now about uh only 35 to 40 percent
maximum of the population would agree
for us to join NATO but I definitely
sure that most of the population won't
have peace and since the war it's not
perceived are something that is so near
to us probably
a population do not understand that it
can move forward really fast
population do not support mostly the
being part of the alliance but we do get
a lot of support from Romania from
different uh from United States and
other countries in the on bilateral uh
issues and we have a lot of support
through different programs with NATO and
I and I hope that now that we have
changed the government and the the Prime
Minister which is
uh would
would be probably invested by the
parliament in in the next few days has a
security
um
experience he was a minister of interior
he was a vice minister of information
and Technology Ministry and the
advisor of our president on security
during Richard would make if the
government to do more in explaining to
the population what the benefits of
cooperating with NATO myself I'm a
supporter and since the Minister of
Defense in in the
2010-2014 then this time I was saying
that the only way for Republic of
Moldova a small country we solve these
problems to have its security assured is
to do everything to become a native
member